Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
meinem Kanal!
Heute geht es um das Thema Saatgut Aufbewahrung
und Saatgut Organisation.
Ich zeige euch, wie ich mein Saatgut aufbewahre
und wie ich das so organisiere, dass ich die
Samen, wenn ich sie dann brauche, wenn ich
irgendwas aussehen will in meinem Garten,
schnell und einfach wiederfinde.
Viel Spaß!
In dieser Kiste hier bewahre ich mein gesamtes
Gemüse-Saatgut auf.
Diese Konstellation benutze ich so schon seit
ungefähr sieben Jahren und entsprechend sieht
das auch aus.
Diese Kiste hier, die fällt schon halb auseinander,
das ist alles total zerfleddert.
Wie ich das Ganze organisiert habe, das zeige
ich euch gleich nochmal, aber ich verpasse
meinem Saatgut jetzt erst mal einen Umzug.
Dem gönne ich eine neue Kiste, die hier hat
auch einen Deckel.
Saatgut sollte man immer dunkel lagern, das
konnte ich bei der Kiste hier nicht, die hat
keinen Deckel, deswegen ist es eh höchste
Zeit, dass ich das mal gescheit mache und
in dem Zug kann ich dann auch gleich zeigen,
wie ich mein Saatgut organisiere, also was
für eine Ordnung hier herrscht, damit ich
einzelne Samen ganz schnell wieder finde.
Ich sortiere mein gesamtes Gemüse-Saatgut
nach Pflanzenfamilien, hier haben wir z.B.
erst mal die Kohlgewächse.
Dann kommen die Leguminosen, dann kommen die
Nachtschattengewächse, danach kommen die
Doldenblütler.
Ich weiß, dass nicht jeder so verrückt ist
und alle Pflanzenfamilien auswendig kennt.
Schreibt mir das mal in die Kommentare, ob
ihr die Pflanzenfamilien auswendig kennt,
das würde mich echt interessieren oder ob
ich die einzige verrückte bin, die die mal
auswendig gelernt hat.
Für mich ist das sehr einfach, weil ich sehr,
sehr viele unterschiedliche Gemüsearten anbaue
und natürlich könnte man das auch nach Salat,
Tomaten, Möhren und so weiter sortieren,
aber bei so vielen verschiedenen Gemüsen,
die wir in unserem Garten anbauen und von
denen wir Saatgut lagern, würde es sehr lange
dauern, bis ich dann genau die Möhre unter
all den Gemüsen rausgefunden habe, deswegen
mache ich das mit den Pflanzenfamilien, wenn
du weniger unterschiedliche Gemüse anbaust,
dann kannst du das natürlich auch anders
sortieren.
Für mich funktioniert das so einfach sehr,
sehr gut, aber eben nicht mehr in diesem Karton,
also habe ich mir ein paar neue, hübschere
Unterteilungen gebastelt und da sortiere ich
jetzt die Gemüse ein.
Da habe ich einmal die Kategorie "Sonstige",
weil ich schon immer mal ein paar abgefahrene
Pflanzenfamilien habe, für die ich, von denen
ich nur eine Pflanze anbaue z.B. den Feldsalat,
der ist ein Baldrian Gewächs.
Der braucht jetzt nicht nen eigenen Reiter,
der kommt dann in die "Sonstigen".
Und danach werde ich jetzt alle Gemüse hier
in die neue Kiste einsortieren, sodass ich
es wieder ganz schön ordentlich habe für
die neue Gartensaison.
Ich habe gerade tatsächlich ein Bananen Saatgut-Tütchen
in meinen Kreuzblütlern gefunden.
Was machst du denn da?
Übrigens hat schon mal jemand von euch "Flower
Sprouts" angebaut?
Das ist so eine neue Kreuzung aus Rosenkohl
und Grünkohl.
Ich will das dieses Jahr Mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe die letztens in einem Restaurant
gegessen und fand die ziemlich lecker!
Also wenn damit schon mal jemand Erfahrungen
hatte, schreibt mir gerne mal ein Kommentar.
Noch ein spannendes Experiment dieses Jahr
sind Erdnüsse, die habe ich schon gesät.
Und bei der Gelegenheit merke ich auch gerade,
dass ich noch gar keine Leguminosen Unterteilungen
für mein neues Kartönchen habe.
Die müssen wir gleich noch basteln.
Kennt ihr diese Teile hier, die immer in Schuhkartons
drin sind?
Das sind so kleine Silizium Kugeln, die Feuchtigkeit
aufnehmen, die packe ich immer mit zu meinem
Saatgut.
Saatgut sollte man nämlich immer dunkel,
trocken und eher kühl lagern, also nicht
an die Heizung stellen.
Deckel drauf ist jetzt schon mal sehr gut
und dann packe ich die Dinger rein, damit
die die Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen und die Samen
möglichst trocken bleiben.
Die Leguminosen hatten noch keine Unterteilung,
deswegen zeige ich euch kurz, wie ich die
gebastelt habe diese Unterteilungen.
Einfach ein Stück Pappe ausgeschnitten, das
in den Karton reinpasst, als Unterteilung.
Und dann habe ich da Tonpapier, so gemustertes,
draufgeklebt, da schreibe ich dann oben in
die Ecke noch "Leguminose" drauf und schon
fertig.
Fertig ist meine Saatgutkiste, der Deckel
passt gerade so noch obendrauf und viel mehr
Saatgut dürfte ich nicht besitzen.
Also werde ich mich wahrscheinlich nächstes
Jahr nochmal nach einer zweiten Kiste umsehen
müssen.
Aber für dieses Jahr wird es wohl ausreichen
und es ist wieder alles ganz schön ordentlich
sortiert mit den Pflanzenfamilien Schildern.
Verratet mir mal unten in den Kommentaren,
wie ihr euer Saatgut lagert.
Da drüben gibt es ein Video zu meinen fünf
allerliebsten Tomatensorten, also wenn du
dich fragst, welche Tomaten du anbauen solltest.
Schau mal da drüben vorbei!
Da unten ist auch noch ein spannendes Video.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da wieder!
Bis dann!
Ciao!